ciao ragazzi siamo qui nella spiaggia di
camera mia
siamo sempre qui facciamo si parte dalle
vacanze ma per adesso siamo qui con un
uomo video che ho deciso di proporvi c'è
il tanque del bikini che cos'è il taste
bikini vedete perche da quando sono
piccola vena 12 anni mi sono fermato lì
e non ho mai cambiato più tanto taglia
quindi ho collezionato negli anni tanti
civic in ear non potervi avanti no e ho
deciso di fare di occupati ad asta
quindi magari parla di quelli che mi
sono sempre piaciuti i più duri quelli
che ho promesso eccetera eccetera
celebrante tete cariche
partiamo con i crediti iva che primo da
allora il primo sta direi è quello dei
bikini storici quelli che ho comprato
anni fa che ho messo usato riusato è
infatti solo perché mente a pezzi cioè
ritengo giusto per ricordo ovviamente le
perline sono tutte mollate poi come
potete vedere è abbastanza grandino
perché io avevo delle tette una volta
poi sono dimagrita e io perche e stessa
cosa questo quadro stato le perline
anzi con le stelline particolare che ero
stata voleste liegro presa questo e poi
in questo cosa un po dopo il periodo
delle perline leopardato già inizia ma
comunque la sobrietà di marina e questo
l'ho messo rimesso tant'è che è tutto
completamente rovinato cioè lo tengo
giusto per ricordo
secondo a star gli errori clamorosi
aggiungerei a tutela sia capitato di
comprarci un costume è anche quello che
ho comprato era top
e poi non è mai suddividere gli errori
in consapevoli e inconsapevoli questo è
un mio errore inconsapevole mi piaceva
come mi stava ma nel momento in cui l'ho
comprato non ho pensato che questo
colore
perché
infatti non ho mai messo non significa
anche insipido terribile parliamo degli
errori e consapevoli questo mi piaceva
era il saldo era una taglia più della
miele più grande della mia cosa fai non
lo compri ho contattato ho comprato non
l'ho mai messo così a caso bello carino
enorme vabbè acquisti online
ecco già difficile comprare online
vestiti scarpe ecc in cui annunci
costumi cioè che è una cosa ci deve
stare perfettamente disegnato sul palco
ecco io questo è stato comprato questo
costume che alla modella di riferimento
stava stile cari gender
io sempre lo saccottino come mai non si
sa questo è il bello degli acquisti
online e ho comprato anche questo che
sempre alla fantastica modella del sito
stava benissimo e io invece sembro
impiccata passiamo alla jacques i
dolorosi e voi vi chiederete ma che cosa
di doloroso questo caso dico questo mio
che carino e bellissimo maria dovrei
preso poi sapere che cosa c'è di
doloroso
ve lo faccio subito vedere questo
ferretto che puntualmente quando meno te
l'aspetti qui si conficca nello sterno e
ti lascia un segno e devi oltre a un
dolore lancinante
questo è un hashtag bruttissimo lascia
veramente deludente cioè quello degli
incidenti che cosa sono i genitori
felini sono i costumi bianchi che
compriamo e sono bianchi proprio che tu
così tic illuminano propositi riflettono
luce sono veramente meravigliosi e
risaltano staff ronza tura cosa
succederà dopo che diventano gialle reso
questo costume adesso con le luci di
barusso non si vede bene ma vi assicuro
che non è più bianco come quando ho
comprato è un giallino è un'opera è
semplicemente da buttare
e passiamo una categoria che qualche
anno fa era il trend della verità il
freno niente costumi prima di noi a 1 e
diciamo che adesso possiamo permettere
di comprare perché sono un po passati ma
comunque ci piaceva passeggiare e
sfilare come degli evidenziatori per la
spiaggia era un trend molto forte come
potete vedere nel mio armadio dominava
il fucsia ma c'è anche un bellissimo
verde fosforescente questo anche un
effetto un po cascata di tarzan
ma passiamo alla steig slip chiari
poi mi direte che cosa c'è di male cosa
c'è di male
ragazze parliamoci chiaramente non
facciamo le tv di a tutte noi è capitato
almeno una volta nella vita di
svegliarci con la voglia irrefrenabile
di metterci il costume che avevo appena
comprato giallino canalino bianchino
quelli bellissimi chiari
andiamo ma arriviamo è filippo ancora
due sono tomorrow ed è subito alle
cascate noi siamo lì che ed ovviamente
lo sia importante niente dietro per
comunque risolve questo problema
quindi oggi torniamo a casa oggi altra
spiaggia chiedere scusa passiamo ai
costumi impegnativi hashtag impegnativi
che cosa vuol dire vuol dire che vedi
questo costruire negozio ci qualche figo
che particolare starà benissimo la
propri sta benissimo i chip e cioè lo
prendo poi ti chiedi ma come faccio
quando prego persone non voglio unita
alla retico l'aquila le calze a rete
sullo sterno infatti promette mai
ma passiamo alla star di mutandoni o
anche bridget jones
perché perché ha tutte cose da provare
al costume top pochissimo ci piace più
ci sta benissimo avrebbe sopra e sotto
ci rifilano loro i mutandoni che noi
diciamo scusi ma è la taglia giusta si
sia la più piccola ma scusi sembra
costume del del ragazzo no
ecco e poi finiamo per non comprarlo
ovviamente cosa è successo nell'ultimo
periodo che andare in giro come
mutandoni
stati muta e alla moda quindi tutta
siamo corsa comprarci questo fantastico
costume che però non ti ho mai perché
cosa vogliamo
la pancia bianca no quindi è un must
bisogna avere per non metterlo come se
allora come capita con i mutandoni che
ci piace solo la parte di sopra e
ovviamente non compriamo un fumo perché
mutandone sono alla bridget jones
succede anche il contrario quindi
succede che magari il negozio vende solo
lo slip per ragazzi che hanno con todt
si spiaggia pd non il mio caso oppure e
la mutandina ci sta da dio lo switch tra
dio e il sopra malissimo di cosa succede
che inizia una ricerca è finita e tutte
le contro i costumi e noi nei negozi
diciamocelo sentirà parte di sopra di
questo particolare per solo particolare
sfumature del giallo dopo due anni io
sono riuscita a trovare un abbinamento
quindi a star abbinati passiamo a una
categoria molto molto molto delicata e
cioè quella degli annodati a tutela sarà
capitato di dimenticarci di snodare
appunto i nastrini di un costume di un
bikini è di ritrovarci l'anno dopo
pietrificati cioè smuoviamo tutta la
famiglia per chiedere di slow darceli
però non si sondano rimangono così e
quindi praticamente sono persi perfetto
ovviamente non poteva mancare la star
sobri cioè la sobrietà prima di tutto
come ben sapete come dico sempre io ecco
i miei costumi più sobri sono questo che
ho messo tantissimo ovviamente catene
oro strano marina 3b 0 4 su questo mezzo
c'era anche questo ci avevo preso
qualche anno un po di anni fa e anche
questo promesso molto ma la chicca la
perla è questo slippino con i dollari ed
è subito rihanna
ed eccoci arrivati alla fine del video
l'ultimo hashtag e i prescelti i
precedenti perché sono quelli che con me
saranno i costumi che metterò di più
questa estate voi vi chiederete ma di
tutti questi costumi maria quale 2020
tutti ne metto pochissimi e cioè quelli
che mi stanno perché
magritte a e sinceramente faccio fatica
a trovare questo mega lisztiano bene ho
trovato questo modello che vi sta bene
come dico io e quindi l'ho preso in
varie fantasie quelle che mi piacciono
di più li prego preso sono questa che
pitonata etico io adoro è questa qui è
come piaceva lo trovo molto molto già
angolo testino no e tutti i due modelli
uguali stanno bene non vi faccio vedere
le foto sapete perché perché ve li
dovrebbe assorbire per tutta l'estate in
tutte le foto gli stemmi tutte le cose
tutti i luoghi tutti i laghi non dovete
quindi far altro seguirvi sul sistema
per vedere copri stando a questi
fantastici vicini sei venduto il video
come al solito
mettete like iscrivetevi al canale e
fatemi sapere con un commento qua sotto
in quale di questi aspetti siete
ritrovati di più e qual è il costume vi
piace di più di quelli che ha visto un
bacione buone vacanze
ciao ragazzi